Erste Stunde in der
Grunewald-Grundschule in Berlin,
Englisch für die 3.Klasse.
Die Lehrerin: Edwige Kamgang.
Sie ist eine sogenannte Quereinsteigerin
und noch in der Ausbildung.
Alle paar Monate sitzt ihre Seminarleiterin
im Unterricht
und überprüft die Fortschritte.
Seit Februar steht die angehende
Lehrerin vor einer Klasse,
ohne pädagogische Vorbildung.
Für die ehemalige Übersetzerin nicht
ganz einfach:
Schule und Ausbildung gleichzeitig.
Es ist ganz schön viel. Das stimmt.
Es ist viel,
wir haben pro Woche
circa zehn Stunden Seminar.
Ich unterrichte 19 Stunden zusätzlich,
dann muss man den Unterricht geben,
vor- und nachbereiten,
Unterrichtsbesuche vorbereiten. Es
ist ganz schön viel.
Die 33-Jährige unterrichtet außerdem
noch Deutsch und Mathe.
Betreut wird sie an der Schule von
einer gestandenen Lehrerin.
Das nennen sie hier
„Professionalisierungskonzept“.
Es ist einzigartig in Berlin.
Quereinsteiger unterrichten ab ihrem
ersten Arbeitstag selbstständig
und zum Teil eben ohne Betreuung.
Und sie haben vorher unter Umständen
kein Praktikum gemacht,
haben auch keine weitere
Lehrerfahrung.
Das heißt, sie müssen Unterstützung
auch aus dem Kollegium bekommen.
Die Quereinsteiger sollen Lücken füllen.
Weil es in Berlin, genauso wie in allen
anderen Bundesländern auch,
mehr Kinder gibt als vorausberechnet.
Wesentlich viel mehr Kinder, sodass in
diesem Jahr mehr als die Hälfte
der in Berlin neu eingestellten
Grundschullehrer Quereinsteiger sind.
Und in den nächsten Jahren sollen
jährlich 2000 Stellen neu besetzt werden.
Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass nicht
genügend Lehrer ausgebildet wurden,
frage ich die Pressesprecherin der
Senatsverwaltung für Bildung,
Jugend und Familie.
Vor 10 Jahren hätte man anders an den
Universitäten schon den
Hebel umlegen müssen,
um jetzt die Lehrkräfte tatsächlich
auch an den Schulen zu haben.
Und warum ist das nicht passiert?
Das müssen Sie die damaligen
Verantwortlichen fragen.
Da kann man natürlich sagen, wir haben
das damals noch nicht gesehen,
was hier auf uns zukommt an
Bevölkerungswachstum.
Und dieses Wachstum hat auch ihr, die
eigentlich Musik studiert hatte,
den Job gebracht.
Sabine Pendl kommt nach einem
12-Stunden-Tag
von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Ich mag meinen Job, sehr. Wirklich.
Und jeden Tag mehr.
Weil ich jetzt nach drei Jahren auch
das Gefühl hab, es läuft.
Im Gegensatz zu jemand[em], der
Lehramt studiert hat,
wurde die Quereinsteigerin gleich an
ihrem ersten Arbeitstag ins
kalte Wasser gestoßen.
Also, es ist was anderes,
ob ich dann ein halbes Jahr lang
in ’ne Klasse gehe, der Klassenlehrer
ist aber immer dabei,
der Klassenlehrer gibt mir Feedback –
die Klassenlehrerin meistens an der
Grundschule –,
und ich bekomme jederzeit die
Unterstützung, die ich brauche.
Oder ob ich alleine vor einer
3., 4., 5., 6. Klasse stehe,
und es heißt: Bitte, Mathe unterrichten!
Sie können doch rechnen.
Und das ist wirklich absurd. Es ist
wirklich …
Ich hab’s absolut komplett absurd gefunden.
Quereinsteiger sind kein Berliner
Problem.
Bundesweit werden über 20.000
Lehrer gesucht.
Auch Edwige Kamgang muss nur eine
18-monatige Ausbildung
hinter sich bringen.
Dann bekommt sie wahrscheinlich eine
unbefristete Festanstellung
und wird wie eine normale Grundschullehrerin
mit einem Monatseinkommen
von über 5000 Euro bezahlt.
Ohne solche Quereinsteiger ist der
Schulbetrieb in Deutschland
nicht mehr zu stemmen.